Nên quan đến vụ xeo tốt kêu thương đâm vào đưa xeo tốt đầu kéo, người hộ quả đặc biệt nghiêm trọc, khiến bác người tử vòng,
sẽ ra vào không dơ mấy bốn phút hong quan bị tâm táng 12 năm 2020,
tại khu vực đủ giữ vở trạm dừng gỵ cao tốt thình vô chiming, lắm thành giấu dây.
Cơ quan kể rất đưa trạm quan tình đồng này đang tính thành sắp mình làm só huyên nhân,
được hiện và chết hiện của các tập thể và cã nhân theo quy định của pháp lật.
Cục kể rất sợ thông đạm só, xe kêu thương bị số 5 mốt bê, 5-2 ba mạ,
tôi không tì chất nhẹn dữ hạn dịch vụ thương ngoại cường phút thôi, phương nhớ lộ thành phố chiming,
đã được ký hợp đồng cũng có chỉ vụ vận chuyển bệnh với bệnh biệt trở dễ.
Ngay mệt sâu tháng 2 năm 2020, theo đề nghị của gia đình bệnh nở tê lợi,
đã nhân đã từ vong trong bụ tên á, bố phận điều xe của bệnh vệnh đã có phiếu điều xe kêu thương đưa bệnh ra vình và đi cùng gia đình.
Bố ngồi, xe đi từ bệnh biệt trở dễ đề phường á nhân đông, tình ra lai mà không có bác sĩ,
ít a đi cùng bệnh nhân.
Lại xe kêu thương là ông đến hữu tê, sinh năm 2020, chú phường phút thôi, kinh phố chiming, đã bật có,
đàn yêu tiên và đi đến địa điểm trên và sế ra tên ánh ra thông,
biệt bật có đàn yêu tiên trong trường hợp này là xa quy định của pháp lật.
Theo quy định của pháp lật, xe ô tồ khu thương chỉ được xử còi, đàn và được quyền yêu tiên khi tham gia ra thông đường bộ trong các trường hợp.
Chẳng với bệnh đi cấp lữ, đi đón người bệnh cấp lữ,
chờ thay thuốc, nhân viên ít a, thuốc, chào tiết bị ít a phục bụng các cứu tham hoạc,
các cứu tên an tất cả những câu cầu các thiết khác của hạt động chiếm mong khá bệnh,
chứ bệnh và phòng trong sức bệnh.
Theo tồ khu thương chỉ được xử dụng tiết bị pháp tỷ kiệu của xe được quyền yêu tiên khi có dế pháp
xử dụng tiết bị pháp tỷ kiệu của xe được quyền yêu tiên còn hiệu lực và khi đang thực hiện những vụ,
theo quy định của pháp lật phay ra thông đường bộ.
Cục kẻ xác xác thông tiết tục chi đạo lực lượng kẻ xác xác thông tàn quốc xích sẽ còn liết các phép xe yーテen.
Sự liết với vị pháp của xe kêu thương, làm dụng mặt phát thì giữ tiên tỷ kiện,
đi đau cũng mặt thì giữ yêu tiên, kinh quyết thù hồi xe phép với xe kêu thương vị pháp.